i have no idea what i'm doing but i know
i'm doing it really really well
oh i'm going to die
i'm so tired
everything hurts running is
impossible april
you're like an angel with no wings so
like a person
donna is it happened once in a dream
chris code name if i had to pick a dude
well i'm fine it's just that life is
pointless and nothing matters and i'm
always tired
april is the best but she's 20.
when april was born i was already in
third grade which means if we were
friends back then i'd have been hanging
out with a baby
i don't know anything about infant care
my god i could have killed her my whole
life is a giant mess and i love it i
mean look at my hair i have gum in my
hair
every time you look up at the moon i too
will be looking at a moon not the same
moon obviously that's impossible
oh my god are you okay
yeah
i'm good
ron and diane sitting in a tree
k-i-s-s-i-s-s-i-p-p
do you hear that bird
boom that's spaghetti
nachos
it's a cookie
i tried to make ramen in the coffee pot
and i broke everything and i
am mother nature's brother
brother nature but you can call me andy
or brother nature
your call thank you andy brother nature
i'm allergic to sushi every time i eat
more than 80 sushis i barf i once forgot
to brush my teeth for five weeks i
didn't actually sell my last car i just
forgot where i parked it i don't know
who al gore is and at this point i'm too
afraid to ask when they say two percent
milk i don't know what the other 98 is
when i was a baby my head was so big
scientists did experiments on me i once
threw a beer at a swan and then it
attacked my niece rebecca that'll do
andrew
what are you doing when i get bummed out
i take my shirt off because the bad
feelings make me feel sweaty
ah
scrawny christians missionaries are you
john rambo he's like yeah go home this
time he says
nope
go home check this out i just invented
it super straw
that is the coolest sentence i've ever
heard somebody talk
you